يهتز داخل الروسي مجددا على وقع ما ترجح
السلطات انه استهداف اوكراني اكثر من نقطه
شهدت انفجارات او محاولات هجوم بمسيارات
وقعت اصابات في مدينه تاجان روج بمقاطعه
روستوف في الجنوب الروسي نتيجه انفجار
بمقهى رجح حاكم المقاطعه ان يكون ناجما عن
اطلاق صاروخ وفي مدينه سماره الى الجنوب
ايضا انفجرت عبوه الناسفه في مصفاه نفط
دون ان تسجل اصابات بينما اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تدمير مسيره اوكرانيه كانت
تحاول مهاجمه منشات في مقاطعه موسكو نافيه
وقوع خسائر في الداخل الاوكراني نفذت
القوات الروسيه هجمات عديده منها في
مقاطعه خاركيف وتحديدا محور كوبيانسك وفق
المتحدث باسم قوات الغرب بالجيش
الروسياق الاعمال العسكريه باتجاه
كوبيانسك وجهت القوات الصاروخيه لمجموعه
قوات الغرب ضربه صاروخيه في منطقه
بلاغوداتانا كما وجهت قوات الدبابات ضربات
الى وحدات اللواء الميكانيكي في مناطق من
خاركيف ادت الى تدمير عدد من الاليات
العسكريه
وتتحدث هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه عن 29
غاره روسيه واكثر من 70 قذيفه صاروخيه
خلال الساعات الماضيه كما اعلنت القوات
الروسيه صدى هجوم للقوات الاوكرانيه في
زابوريا وتدمير عدد من الاليات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه واكد بيان لوزاره الدفاع قصف
مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه في سيفريسك
بالقرب من بخموت التي يتحدث الجانب
الاوكراني عن تقدم تدريجي جنوبي المدينه
التقدم التدريجي مستمر جنوبي بخموت اما في
المناطق الشماليه للمدينه فتصدت قواتنا
لهجمات العدو وفي اتجاه كوبيانس كوليمان
يحاول الجيش الروسي اشغال قواتنا عن
معاركنا الناجحه في بخمر ويهدف دون جدول
اجبار قواتنا على التراجع من المرتفعات
التي تسيطر عليها
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه بدورها قالت ان
قواتها سيطرت على قريه ستارو مايويورك
بمقاطعه
وتصدت لمحاولات تقدم روسيه في الايمان في
المقاطعه نفسها بينما نفذت القوات
الاوكرانيه هجوما على محوري
في مقاطعه